as technology keeps moving faster and
faster I am good with something slower
my finger beneath the words has led me
to a life of writing books for people of
all ages books meant to be read slowly
to be savored sometimes we read to
understand the future
sometimes we read to understand the past
we read to get lost to forget the hard
times we're living in and we read to
remember those who came before us who
live through something harder who are
not allowed to read at all
they too must have circled fires
speaking softly of their dreams their
hopes their Futures each time we read
write or tell a story
we step inside their Circle
and it remains Unbroken
and the power of story
lives on